la france se dit inquiète face à la
propagation du nouveau variant omicron
inquiétude également russie avec des
premiers cas de cette nouvelle souche du
corona virus détecté aujourd'hui chez
des voyageurs en provenance d'afrique du
sud plus de détails avec notre
correspondante à moscou ma liste et
strech deux cas du variant omicron ont
effectivement été détectés chez des
voyageurs testé positif aux ports aux
navires us après un séjour en afrique du
sud et dans des pays limitrophes
tous les passagers positifs ont été
placés en observation selon l'agencé
fédérale sanitaire russe la souche ou
mikron a été confirmée chez deux
patients avec un test pcr positifs
réalisés au cours des 24 premières
heures en centre d'observation à la
suite d'un séquençage pangénomique
réalisée par l'institut central de
recherche en épidémiologie de
rospotrebnadzor
les recherches sur d'autres patients se
poursuivre
la situation fait l'objet de mesures de
contrôle renforcé de rospotrebnadzor
tous les citoyens qui retourne en russie
d'afrique du sud et des pays voisins
subissent des tests à la frontière au
moment de leur arrivée sont examinés et
placés dans des centres d'observation
spécialement organisée à cet effet
d'après l'agent sanitaire ces voyageurs
sont soumis à des tests pcr quotidien et
isolés dans des chambres spéciales en
cas de symptômes ou de résultat positif
ce lundi la russie a enregistré plus de
trente deux mille nouveaux cas de
contamination au co vide et 1884 décès
ces dernières 24 heures ces chiffres
sont en légère baisse par rapport aux
derniers jours vadimir poutine a annoncé
un plan d'action contre le nouveau
variant rappelant l'importance de
maintenir
violence accrue sur l'efficacité des
tests et des vaccins mais aussi sur les
stocks d'oxygène et la capacité
d'accueil dans les hôpitaux